il
michel perret 34 ans est agriculteur à
mondavezan dont les pyrénées-orientales
au sud de toulouse
il est à la tête d'une exploitation
familiale de 60 hectares michel et d'y
penser depuis deux ans il a un fils de
quatre ans il y as dont il a la garde
un week-end sur deux mais depuis deux
semaines
il vit dans l'angoissé les enfants et sa
mère ont disparu ou et son fils
la question me hante jour et nuit là les
chats autres acteurs j'ai beau être
qu'on sent très bon travail ou ma
conduite
je n'y pensais pas après les questions
se suivent quand c'est que je vais
revoir mon fils ou ce qu'ils sont
qu'est ce qu'il se passe au fur et à
mesure des jours pour lui
à la ferme les traces de la présence de
l'enfant sont partout dès qu'il a un
moment michel retourne au domicile de la
mère dans la ville voisine
à chaque fois michel espère croiser son
ex-femme revoir son fils
mais cette fois encore devant la porte
ils se heurtent au silence voilà
c'est ici que le vent durée que votre
enfant c'est ici comme ailleurs on
empoche donc voila quand je suis arrivé
ça a donné ça exactement
donc qu'est ce qu'on ressent ce moment
là je me devais de la colère il a
plusieurs émotions mélangées
la mère a déménagé sans prévenir elle
est repassée dans la semaine
michel l'apprend devant notre caméra de
la bouche d'un voisin
c'est pas vrai et puisque la voilure
désignés tous les jeux c'est lui enlever
de trois jours la mère et l'enfant sont
passés en cachette
l'épisode hf d'accabler michel
conviendrait les jeux il y avait les jo
s'était pris dans cette semaine puisque
moi j'ai travaillé cette semaine donc à
la venue cette semaine elle venue la cij
ouvre le bout de son nez aux havrais
contre-révolution bon et bienvenue au
club alors super merci mais on est trois
parfois comme ça mais vous isoler sa
famille en bretagne avait partir le
petit mais vous allez s'y rendrait pour
la partie comme une voleuse
les parties avancent à une enquête
sociale pour une raison que connaît même
pas la route en deux ans c'était
compliqué mais c'est venu comme ça les
élus et michel garder l'espoir qu'il
s'agisse d'un malentendu
en réalité son ex femme est parti sans
laisser d'adressé
de retour à la ferme
il raconte tout à sa grand mère simone
82 ans la semaine à doha
elle a alors fini de sortir détaillé
appartement gâteau sa sé in cro ya dix
ans ils sont partis précipitamment
l'école de l'enfant n'a pas été prévenu
j'appelle les petits quelques à l'école
est elle là ranieri sait que la partie
tellement vitale elle l'a laissé tous on
les connaît et c'est vrai que tout a été
abandonnée
jusqu'au 12 ou de l'enfant
michel a compris lorsqu'il a reçu une
lettre de son ex femme ont recommandé 15
jours après leur disparition
rave être calme a rien de moyens et que
tu es parti pour le bonheur de son fils
elle aussi est bon chiffre pour le voir
la mer n'indique aucune adresse comme si
elle voulait rester cachés
quand michel réussi à la joindre au
téléphone elle refuse de l'informer du
lieu où elle se trouve
michel est convaincu d'être victime d'un
rapt parental
il n'a pas l'intention de se laisser
faire
pour certains parents retrouver un
enfant c'est le combat d'une vie à
paradou petit village de provence
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de
cédric à 40 ans ce restaurateur arrêter
de travailler
sa vie est toute entière tournée vers un
seul but récupérer sa fille la garde lui
en a été retiré pour être confiée à sa
mère une jeune allemand qui reparti dans
son pays avec l'enfant en 2007 sa petite
fille est née d'une histoire d'amour
avec adriana c'est vrai qu'à alors 33
ans
la vie lui sourit
quatre ans plus tard en 2011 le couple
se désagrège dans un premier temps les
deux parents vont s'accorder devant un
juge
la mère obtient la garde de l'enfant
sous réserve qu'elles restent vivre en
france mais peu de temps après elle
s'installe en allemagne
cédric nous fait écouter cet
enregistrement qui l'a mis sur internet
pour montrer que sa fille souhaiterait
vivre avec lui en france vient vraiment
vite et là on va tout et mes copines ali
que telle et comptait même pas
aujourd'hui de vivre dans un pays dont
elle n'a pas envie donc ça ne lui plaît
pas à la le droit c'est pas parce
qu'elle a sept ans qu'on doit lui
imposer de vivre une vie qu'elle n'a pas
envie de vivre
et pour ça ça veut pas dire qu'elle
n'aime pas sa maman ça veut pas ça veut
pas dire non plus qu'elle aime plus son
papa c'est que cette petite fille a fait
le choix au fond de son coeur dans cette
situation qui est dramatique pour elle
aujourd'hui la fillette habitat 1300 km
de la provence pour tenter de ramener sa
fille en france tout au moins de la
recevoir pour les vacances
cédric a entamé un véritable parcours du
combattant entre les justices française
et allemande
tout a commencé ici chez laure anne une
amie de cédric c'est elle qui gardait
soléa le jour où sa mère est venu la
récupérer
c'était il ya quatre mois d'un café la
mère de soleil à est venu chercher sa
fille avec l'aide des gendarmes
les français obéissait à une réquisition
de la justice allemande exigent que la
fillette soit remise à sa mère on était
à table
en fait c'était voilà le début de la
soirée ont mangé
et voilà je lui ai expliqué que son papa
allait venir la chercher mais que mais
qui avait un gros problème est que et
que malheureusement il serait accompagné
des gendarmes et 2 et de la maman parce
que la biologie à l est et s'est
décomposé
elle s'est décomposé parce que tout d'un
coup tout d'un coup elle a réalisé que
voilà que
peut-être qu'elle allait devoir repartir
et c'était peut-être là tout de suite
maintenant et donc du coup c'était
c'était terrible l'a pris dans ses bras
et lui a dit mais je t'en supplie me
laisse pas vraiment eu ma premier me
laisse pas
la dernière image que cédric conserve de
sa fille
c'est son départ entre deux uniformes
elle n'aura pas le droit de repasser
chez son père ni de prendre le moindre
jouer cédric est resté sous le choc
l'épisode lui rappelle le souvenir d'une
autre histoire la sienne en 1986 29 ans
plus tôt l'odyssée d'un jeune garçon
fait la une des médias
cédric cet enfant dé 12 ans dont les
parents se disputent la garde
c'est le rêve qui a décidé récemment de
faire 450 kilomètres pour retrouver son
père alors âgé de 12 ans cédric s'est
enfuie de chez sa mère à qui il a été
confié après le divorce de ses parents
il va raconter avoir parcouru 450
kilomètres en auto stop pour rejoindre
son père l'histoire bouleverse le petit
village de provence qui se mobilisent
devant les caméras pour empêcher les
gendarmes de venir prendre l'enfant
cédric et son père essaye de se
retrouver pour l'enfant le choix est
fait depuis longtemps
d'ici nous faire gagner pas la garde et
j'ai eu d'affairé et tu penses pas que
ta mère que tu es mis en dessous non je
ne fais pas lui serait plus là bas et
quand même fou une clientèle pour moi
n'existe plus oui je vois ça imoca ont
pressé tout la sphère va changer le
cours de l'histoire
répondant à l'émotion que soulève ce
fait divers
l'assemblée nationale adopte une loi qui
oblige les juges à écouter le choix d'un
enfant avant de statuer sur sa garde
l'histoire familiale de cédric devient
un débat de société
cédric g alain delon cayla est ce que tu
as quelque chose à lui dire
cédric je voudrais te dire que tu as
fait c'est très très beau et moi
personnellement ça m'a beaucoup ému et
je suis très heureux que tu aies obtenu
satisfaction et on perd aussi n'en veut
pas trop par moments elle thème prends
bien soin d'elle quand tu la verras
voilà c'est vrai aujourd'hui
l'histoire semble se répéter c'est
toujours vers son père que cédric vient
chercher du soutien à chaque étape de
son marathon judiciaire justice
allemande justice française
cédric attaquent sur tous les fronts ça
va pas ça va résultat elles ont mis en
délibéré le 13 février
pour moi la politique
le grand-père de soleil à semble encore
plus affecté que son fils soit là a le
même sort que son papa chéri vous
imaginez un et compte que c'était 1,86
sa mère est venue à l'école à nous gaver
de forces éparses a été tué et que des
amis il ya la nar moring et tous et sa
poésie de vie elle et sa rivale mais mon
choix par c10 et si si si c'est fou ça
mais je pus et or plus il pleure on peut
re tous parce que enfin devenus amis se
bat mais c'est les verts a pas photo
c'est cédric lui ne se résignent pas à
cette fatalité pour ramener sa fille
il est prêt à porter sa croisade au delà
des frontières
au sud de toulouse nous retrouvons
michel miné par le départ soudain de son
ex femme et de son fils et sur les
conseils d'une association
il va voir les gendarmes pour signaler
leur disparition
je venais de déposer une plaine de
pronoms représentation d'une banque
j'en avais déjà déposé donc on peut dire
n'apprennent une situation qui me
réconforte de verre de bordeaux puis
parce que avec cette plainte
michel espère surtout se constituer un
dossier avant d'aller porter l affaire
devant la justice
à saint gaudens nous sommes allés
rencontrer l'avocat que michel a engagé
pour lui dans ce genre d'affaires il
faut réagir vite
on sait très bien que dans ce genre de
situation il faut être très rapide
puisque dès lors qu'il ya une situation
de fait qui s'installe je veux dire par
là que si l'un des parents par avec
l'enfant en faisant le coup de force
si les choses se stabilisent dans une
région x6 l'enfant après semble être
bien avec ce parent
il est il est fréquent que le juge
considère que la situation de fait ne
pose plus de problèmes que l'intérêt de
l'enfant et donc de rester dans cette
situation et donc par voie de
conséquence je dirais que c'est un peu
trop tard au nom de michel maître
malaisie a engagé une procédure
d'urgence un référé pour demander la
garde de l'enfant
cela fait maintenant deux mois que
michel et sa grand mère n'ont pas revu
igas à la ferme
tout le monde pense à lui mais ce matin
est un jour d'espoir michel se met sur
son 31
il a rendez vous au tribunal alors une
aventure est oui
michel va demander à la justice la
résidence principale de son fils à plein
temps chez lui à la ferme
il me manque de moi c'est l'autre ne pas
voir son fils pendant deux mois c'est
long c'est extrêmement long j'espère le
voir rapidement le voir et l'avoir
rapidement
j'espère c'est aujourd'hui que c'est
sous sa sage aujourd'hui bon la décision
c'est au tribunal de grande instance de
saint-gaudens que michel est convoqué
par un juge aux affaires familiales
l'audience a lieu à 9 heures du matin
son ex femme est déjà là dans la salle
d'audience
l'agriculteur va devoir faire face à la
mère de son fils accompagné d'un avocat
elle est bien décidée à tout faire pour
conserver la garde de son enfant
la procédure se déroule à huis clos
l'audience dure 20 minutes michel
ressort secoué son ex femme l'accuse
d'être un père et un compagnon violent
sortie en colère
c'est à dire c'est surtout un avocat
d'anna par quatre verres ça en quelques
mots qui ont été assez compliqué à
vendre votre pronostic c'est très très
difficile à dire très très difficile il
ya quand même une disparition du jour au
lendemain sans prévenir
jamais ça c'est certain c'est ce que
nous avons plaidé au premier chef
bon j'espère que le modem le juge sera
s'y retrouver dans tout cela à la sortie
du tribunal
nouveau coup de théâtre sous le regard
de sa cliente l'avocat de son ex femme
revient sur les marches du palais
interpellé michel
ils l'accusent d'avoir proféré des
menaces de mort à l'encontre de son fils
michel et près d'en venir aux mains
c'est son avocat qui le retient la mère
a assisté à l'esclandre sans le moindre
mot nous l'avons contactée elle n'a pas
souhaité répondre à nos questions
c'est monstrueux un truc énorme
je vais me faire avocat mange trop parce
que si c'est que samantha des histoires
les accusations de violence ou de
maltraitance sont monnaies courantes
devant les juges aux affaires familiales
sur le chemin du retour
michel s'interroge sur la manoeuvre de
l'avocat
je pense qu'il cherchait à me faire
sortir de mes gonds pour justement faire
valoir la france l'accusation comme ça
mais il aurait eu il sera déposé plainte
mais bon la juge aurait vu la plaine de
ce
de ce qu'il aurait souhaité quoi
comme ça mais moi j'avais tout perdu et
il aurait tout va bien tout simplement
selon vous c'était un piège ah oui j'ai
fait j'ai failli tomber lausanne est
alors j'ai failli tomber le dal et de
pivoine
le délibéré ce nom et non pas vers la
sortie du tribunal sans faille et
chauffée et pourquoi tu sais pas de quoi
il m'a accusé
son avocat elle qui m'a dit comme ça
vous m'avez dit que vous alliez m
confusion votre fils ou là là c'est
failli sortir niveau là j'ai failli
sortir
l'après midi même
michel retourne à la gendarmerie à
l'occasion de l'audience il a pu
récupérer la nouvelle adresse de son ex
femme
un détail qui fait toute la différence
selon le premier jugement de divorce
s'est à son tour d'avoir son fils pour
les vacances paulo pour convaincre la
mère au téléphone michel demande le
soutien des gendarmes
l'officier accepte de faire
l'intermédiaire pour dire à la mer que
michel veut récupérer son fils pour
quelques jours
mais après une demi heure de tractations
déception les gendarmes ont bien réussi
à joindre la mère du petit garçon mais
elle reste inflexible
ali a tout simplement dit que elle me
donnait pas non plus jusqu'au jugement
du 24 3 comme mon fils et de ses parfums
de cause face aux déplacements pour
aller chercher je ne leur ai pas dit ça
mais là ça me met en colère
là on est au moins savait en colère
s'est même posé cette chaîne là c'est de
la colère parce que elle croit s'en
prendre à moi c'est vrai d'un côté mais
elle se rend pas compte que s'en
prennent directement à notre fils est
encore difficile à admettre pour michel
bien qu'il soit dans son droit
les gendarmes à distance n'ont rien pu
faire
il ne lui reste plus qu'à attendre que
la justice statue sur sa demande de
garde
un mois plus tard dans son tracteur
michel compte les jours
régulièrement il appelle son avocat pour
savoir si le tribunal a rendu son
verdict
oui m avant l'asie
oui bon d'accord
ouais mais est bien un peu beaucoup ou
malheureux je suis dans notre acteur
mais je me retienne vrai je vais pas
tarder à traverser le plafond il je
crois moi ça c'est pas moi ça c'est pas
mal du tout
pour les maîtres mots lui pendant la
potée sait si c'est vrai numéro masqué à
l'automne une seconde à l'eau bon après
oui mais bon on a appelé m en asie le
pauvre qui viennent du ciel pendant le
petit je regarde apportez vos rues le
départ inopiné de la mer lui aura
finalement coûté cher les juges
sanctionnent généralement celui des
parents qui empêche l'autre de conserver
une relation équilibrée avec son enfant
michel a gagné sur le papier mais il
doit ronger son frein
son avocat lui a demandé d'attendre
avant d'aller chercher son fils que le
jugement soit signifié par courrier à
son ex femme
mais au petit matin
changement de ton michel a pris une
décision il ne suivra pas les conseils
de son avocat il craint que son ex femme
ne décide de déménager de nouveau il ne
veut plus prendre le risque d'attendre
il part pour la normandie retrouver son
fils par tous les moyens au petit
déjeuner
simone la grand-mère s'est levé avec un
mauvais pressentiment elle redoute le
traumatisme d'une séparation brutale
entre l'enfant et sa mère est comme ça
mais je pense qu'ils nous sommes à bord
ou tu me parles tu sais bien mais je ne
peux pas m'en séparer sam odio fait
quand même mal que moi c'est parti pour
la quitter
mais ma lame de la scie elba et elle lui
le pauvre lui babol qui voulaient me
renvoyer pas parce que tu crois vraiment
je vous dis c'est tout quoi michel lui
n'a pas d'états d'âme
il a la certitude que son fils sera
euros à la ferme
sa crainte c'est au contraire de ne pas
faire assez vite
il a récupéré par mail une copie du
jugement et mis cap au nord
800 kilomètres plus loin ils arrivent à
destination
une cité dans la banlieue de rouen
beaucoup déjà sur le petit parking
séjour aventure pour s'assurer que son
ex femme est bien là ils fouillent les
parkings avec l'idée de repérer sa
voiture il n'imaginait pas se retrouver
dans un vaste quartier hlm
l'agriculteur est un peu perdu
win qui faisait passer pour raconter ici
on y est 31 non c'est non
donc j avant de monter michel veut
joindre son ex femme au téléphone il ne
l'a pas encore prévenu de sa démarche
oui c'est moi voyez en grèce que pas été
mis au courant de résultats du juge
de votre ferr bon moi je suis au courant
j le jugement sous les yeux donc manger
en garde du petit à partir de hier à
l'autre bout du fil son ex femme paraît
surprise
comment j'ai la garde de il ya ce à
partir d'hier depuis hier donc vu que
j'ai regardé d'ilyas depuis hier de
demain matin je vais chercher il ya ce
que prépare ce qu'il faut je viens le
chercher les bonnes matin et je tape on
est jeté et je te porte le jugement et
ne veut pas en entendre parler
non non tu peux faire ce que tu veux tu
dois me remettre petit alors soit on me
fait ça amiable parce que je veux qu'on
le fasse amiable soit je viens avec un
policier bon elle a raccroché
ça c'est fait ça va être compliqué de
retrouver notre fils d'amener
circonstances comme ça c'est pas le
meilleur que j'aurais aimé non mais bon
c'est pas celle que j'aurais préféré mes
mots
je préfére amiable odinga se soit calmée
muni d'une simple copie du jugement
michel ne peut pas demander l'assistance
de la police ou des gendarmes
mais il a l'intention d'essayer
le lendemain matin aux premières heures
du jour il est pris de court il a été
réveillé par un coup de téléphone de son
ex-femme météo au téléphone elle lui
apprend qu'elle n'est plus à rouen et
qu'elle a trouvé refuge à paris dans la
nuit mais son attitude a changé elle
semble prête à respecter la décision de
justice
rendez vous est pris le jour même à
paris comme dans un jeu de piste michel
reprend la route avec l' angoisse de se
faire balader
trois heures plus tard il découvre paris
et trouve la porte de clignancourt le
lieu du rendez vous
il ne lui reste plus qu'à attendre
après une demi heure son ex-femme le
retrouve dans sa voiture avec l'enfant
donc c'est clair on ne s'inquiète pas
après lecture du jugement
la mère du lias accepte de lui confier
l'enfant mais elle ne partira pas sans
affirmer qu'elle s'est bien occupé de
son fils et que ce n'est que contrainte
et forcée qu'elle se résout à le laisser
davies williams mais comprennent comment
je sais pas pour cent que je prends
et voilà ça y est aux côtés de me voir
comme ça me venir à maison oui aux modos
doit à tamesna mais oui c'est vrai ya
pourquoi dans la maison c'est un rappel
répondront ayez oui il y est pas bon
c'est vrai
un tracteur voit la fin du mois
ça va quand même ça s'est bien passé bon
c'est sûr que le ch est attristé
attristait aussi ça me faisait parce
qu'on a peine à voir comme ça aussi il
faut dire ce qui est michel ne traîne
pas à paris tout à sa joie
il repart à la ferme avec son fils
montataire et au québec mais un goût
après quatre mois d'attenté de recherche
michel peut retourner à une vie normale
ce n'est pas encore le cas de cédric
nous le retrouvons chez lui en provence
il multiplie les recours judiciaires
mais il va de déception en déception
depuis deux mois il attend le résultat
d'un appel déposé au tribunal
d'aix-en-provence
les magistrats n'ont pas tranché en sa
faveur
la justice privilégie la stabilité de
l'enfant qui vit depuis un an et demi en
allemagne
solea reste confiée à sa mère
et le lendemain de ce jugement
cédric a reçu un nouveau coup de massue
l'office allemand de protection de
l'enfance le jugendamt lui a adressé une
lettre très inquiétante
ce courrier il ya un an en fait c'est le
jugendamt alors gagner de la protection
de l'enfance comme il est considéré en
allemagne qui écrit une lettre au
tribunal de nos stats disant qu'il
fallait moto de me retirer l'autorité
parentale supprimer droit de visite
à en croire ce courrier cédric n'aurait
plus le droit de voir sa fille
outre-rhin sous peine d'être arrêté par
la police
une situation a priori incompréhensible
et en attendant d'y voir plus clair
son avocat lui a déconseillé désormais
de s'approcher du domicile de la mère et
de l'enfant
aujourd'hui non seulement qu'on ait
relevé mon enfant je cours le risque
d'être incarcéré en allemagne cette
situation comment mais ça tient pas
debout
c'est de l'absurdité la plus totale et
notre gouvernement français nous laisse
complètement tombée on est complètement
abandonné face à ce rouleau compresseur
administrative de l'allemagne la france
vient même pas vous tendant la main
cerise sur le gâteau l'administration
allemande lui réclame une pension
alimentaire rétroactive de près de 5000
euros pour compenser une aide sociale
que l'état allemand à verser à son ex
compagne depuis trois ans nous avons
joint l'ex-femme de ces briques mais
elle a refusé toutes nos demandes
d'interview en 2013
la mère de soldats avaient reçu une
équipe de télévision chez elle dans la
région d'hanovre
voici ce qu'elle déclarait moi jamais
j'ai préféré ce soit sur le pape a
jamais mais il faut qu'il me prouve que
je peux lui faire confiance à ce tout ce
que je demande vous avez demandé à
supprimer les droits de visite en
allemagne les droits de visite ça veut
dire c'est à dire que cédric ne puisse
plus voir ses films
non ça c'est faux alors moi j'ai des
papiers qui disent que vous demander la
suppression du droit de visite
est-ce que je peux le voir les papiers
parce que c'est bien sûr sa signature
sur ce document l'avocate de la mère
demande au tribunal de supprimer à
cédric son droit de visite et son
autorité parentale le droit de la
famille allemand permet ce type de
mesures radicales au bénéfice de parents
allemands
la mère de soléa semble surprise de la
démarche de son avocate
ce choc est parce que tu jamais demandé
de supprimer le droit de visite
non
cédric lui est décidé à jouer une
dernière carte pour tenter de ramener sa
fille en france
est ce que fait ma prix des filles dans
le nord de l'allemagne à ouaga pson.l à
tous ses repères ses racines et plus
profond en france elle a été à l'école
la crèche à l'école maternelle au cp
ça c'était un désastre considère petit
défi
désastre ce matin là il part pour
bruxelles son espoir c'est de porter l
affaire devant les institutions
européennes pour faire changer les lois
allemandes
non
l'histoire de cédric n'est pas un cas
isolé
des centaines de parents dans toute
l'europe sont dans des situations
comparables
la cour européenne de justice a déjà
condamné l'allemagne pour des pratiques
discriminatoires envers des parents
étrangers d'enfants allemand
ce jour-là une commission du parlement
européen doit examiner une nouvelle
plainte contre l'allemagne portée par
des citoyens venant de toute l'europe
cédric retrouve d'autres parents parmi
eux lionel il n'a pas vu ses enfants
depuis des années ils ont tous les deux
rendez vous avec un député français qui
a pris fait et cause pour ses pairs
privés de leurs enfants
messieurs c'est vous dire bonjour à
chanter j'ai dû passer ma mauvaise
il tente depuis des années de faire
évoluer la législation allemande
il faut refuser ce diktat c'est
acceptable
il ya des gens qui vont en allemagne qui
tombe amoureux ou amoureuse d'allemand
ou d'allemande et qui se marient et puis
comme la vie est comme ça et parfois les
divorces et avec les allemands ça se
passe très très mal et c'est une
particularité sur le territoire européen
mais les ces enfants qui sont séparés de
leurs parents qui sont arrachés à leurs
parents pour des problèmes de
législation mal appliquées ou ou dont on
ne veut pas entendre parler
agir c'est laisser des citoyens
européens ces enfants là il ya les
droits de l'enfant qu'il faut qu'on
défende les droits de l'homme
il est 17 heures c'est dans cette salle
du parlement que va avoir lieu
l'audition des parents en colère contre
la législation allemande la commission
denquête est présidée par trois députés
européens
le député français est au premier rang
et voici le représentant de la
délégation allemande
le député renner vilalte français
italiens grecs
dans la salle les plaignants viennent de
toute l'europe
il y a même un allemand venu contester
sa propre législation refuge sauver vos
services je prépare deux projets et
éternellement
j'aurais quand même présenter mes
excuses à tous les parents et les
pauvres selon vous a fait je me suis dit
wow je souffre comme vous je dire merci
pendant deux heures les témoignages
révèlent la dureté avec laquelle
l'administration allemande traite les
parents étrangers en conflit avec ses
ressortissants donc aujourd'hui je suis
condamné à 80 jours de prison ou à 2400
euros d'amendé j'ai été emprisonné en
novembre 2012
parallèlement je pensais la parole pour
l'as far 2 pour la part de cédric
laurent et vient de découvrir qu'il a un
arriéré de 6000 euros qu'il doit à
l'état allemand parce que son ex femme
sans le savoir de la justice française
avec l'accord de la justice allemande
perçoit des aides sociales de
l'allemagne depuis 2011
monsieur rhyner wieland est là et pourra
me regarder il est peut-être temps que
l'allemagne pense que on est en europe
le député français conclut jour
inadmissible il y a un an il y a eu des
décisions prises en france par des
juridictions qui ont été remises en
cause dans un second temps par
l'allemagne par le jugendamt c'est
inadmissible je souhaite que l'on
demande à la commission européenne de
lancer un avertissement
à l'allemagne pour qu'elle prenne ses
responsabilités et qu'elle engage des
processus qui puisse aider ses parents
là et ces familles en souffrance
je vous dis de mon point de vue c'est
non assistance à personne en danger
le représentant allemand tente de
dédouaner son pays face à des parents
qui parlent le droit de garder droit de
visite
il fait mine de réduire le débat à un
différend sur le versement de pension
alimentaire
j'appellerai un chat un chat il s'agit
de cas de violations de pension
alimentaire
ça n'a rien à voir avec le droit
européen en l'occurrence l'europe n'est
concerné que lorsqu'il s'agit de droit
européen
ici la question est de savoir dans
quelle mesure les états ont une
indépendance de droit
la question est de savoir dans quel cas
les états ont le droit de ne s'en tenir
qu'à leur propre législation les
violations des droits à la pension
alimentaire ne relève pas de la
commission sans attendre la fin de la
séance le député allemand quitte la
salle
les parents en colère repartiront
toutefois avec une petite victoire
le bureau du parlement accepte
d'examiner leurs plaintes
nous accompagnons cédric à berlin il
fait le déplacement dans la capitale
allemande pour rencontrer un avocat
français installés outre rhin réputé
pour sa connaissance de la législation
allemande des affaires familiales
cédric vaut savoir ce qu'il risque s'il
approche du domicile de la mère pour
tenter de voir soléa
après 30 ans de carrière auprès de
couples binationaux
l'avocat m revel ne fait pas dans la
langue de bois si j'étais vous jouerez
un petit peu peur aussi un ben oui vous
savez il y à la théorie à la pratique
dans la pratique si la maman ne veut pas
que le vab a emmené son enfant en france
a fallu remettre tout simplement ce qui
veut dire est que le système a rendu la
cour d'appel d'aix-en-provence
si elle ne veut pas demain c'est fou
c'est non donc de valider au libre choix
de la marque exactement
comme ça c'est difficile enfin qu'on ne
leur en veux pas la maman est tout à
fait prioritaire dans la société
allemande l'enfant appartient à la maman
le père n'est que le progéniteurs enfin
ressorti sa vieille france fait un
enfant avec un français le travail en
france des emplois en france pour la
séparation des statuts monsieur est ce
que je disais que j'étais jeune j'ai
baisé
si ça c'est comme ça cédric se sentent
abandonnés par les autorités françaises
qu'est ce qui s'est passé cause
des révélations en révélations
quand vous entendez un avocat qui vous
dira mais sur orange et de baisers
à ce moment-là gauche au monde il agit
selon pays
direction hanovre malgré les risques
cédric a décidé d'aller chercher sa
fille pour les vacances comme la justice
française lui en donne le droit
au petit matin cédric à une dernière
conversation avec son avocate
sans solution judiciaire en allemagne il
se résout à négocier avec son ex
compagne une trêve
une sorte de parenthèse dans le
feuilleton judiciaire qui les oppose
on verra sur le moment avec la maman et
comment ça se passe avec soléa mais je
peux pas forcer mon enfance il ne le
veut pas voilà cédric fait profil bas
c'est ce que voulait entendre l'avocate
pour donner des garanties à la mer une
heure plus tard il reçoit un texto la
mère demande à cédric de la rappeler
elle est prête à lui laisser sa fille
quelques jours c'est génial
elle confie à cédric être lassé des
procédures judiciaires qui n'en
finissent plus je suis content
d'entendre dire ça je suis exactement
dans la même démarche à rihanna je
souhaite se passer pour le mieux est ok
allez hop irez-vous voir tout de suite
je suis super heureux c'est évident je
suis pas je suis pas d'un d'une forte
opposition aujourd'hui en étant ici du
jeu
je me souviens aux conditions mais je
vois que la mer est très conciliante
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui me réconforte
en tout cas faut vraiment mettre sa
rancoeur le passif susan auch faut
mettre son ego sa fierté
même si on entend des choses qui sont
décalées il faut vraiment être faut
faire profil bas sinon voix puis son
enfant c'est tout comme par miracle la
mer viendra une heure plus tard avec
soléa les deux parents des jeunes font
comme si de rien n'était
le soir cédric retrouvera sa fille
depuis le couple a retrouvé une relation
apaisée
la petite soléa vite en allemagne avec
sa mère mais elle vient régulièrement
retrouvé son père et son grand-père en
provence
et voyez
retournez voir michel l'agriculteur au
sud de toulouse
il y as vite à la ferme il a trouvé ses
repères
c'est magnifique de l'ordre enfin tous
les maux qui sont synonymes magnifique
comme pour les images
michelle wie le bonheur d'élever son
fils au quotidien
la mère du lias est revenu s'installer à
toulouse elle voit son fils tous les
week-ends
et
les